this is an honor here on the rich eisen
show on the 41st
anniversary of the miracle on ice the
goalie who stopped 36 of 39
shots to beat the soviets and the man
who called the action
uh for the olympics jim craig and al
michaels here together
on the rich eisen show happy anniversary
guys
41 years it's amazing incredible
it must make you like 47 years old
i was i was actually seven
and you were hit you were two i was two
don't wish
i think back to uh when we did uh the
wrap-up show that night the sunday night
after the finland game and
jim mckay brings me in and ken dried and
then he
he said do you think this will live on
for a while
and i didn't want to say for sure
because
otherwise you know in case it didn't
that would look like a dope
but if he would have said 41 years later
people are still
talking about this and exalting
uh that was a miracle yeah kind of crazy
right
so i mean let's if you don't mind just
let's start
um our chat here about the day
uh jim what what what are your
recollections about
waking up that day and starting your day
knowing what the day could actually hold
for you
jim well you know in your life you
always look at
opportunities that you're going to get
and you you want to make the most of
them
i i just remembered in preparation my
preparation was so different for that
game
uh because we had played them in madison
square garden
i i didn't play the whole game they
played some it was a
incredible as i look at it
strategic thing that herb did but for me
to have played them before became so
important
to be able to prepare for them for the
second time right
so you know i i looked at it in all
honesty that if you played one period
against the russians
it was equivalent to a whole game
against any other team
and so i i broke the game into three
separate games of four or five minute
periods and so i could concentrate and
be
really laser focused and then broke the
game into like you can't let him score
in the third period
because that was the most important
momentum wise and so
when i did that the game moved along
faster and it was easier to
uh prepare and
you know goalie's position is so
different because you can't go out and
be excited you have to
react to the game and and really try to
control the momentum
in in a very favorable way like if your
team scores a goal
you try not to give up a goal very
quickly and momentum is such an
important thing and we had that home
crowded and had been building
and so for me it was really the
excitement of having this opportunity
that
so many people had helped me uh along
the way
that i was i was ready for it you know
it was really fun for me i
i i kind of liked those type of moments
what about you al
when i woke up that morning i thought
well you know this is a very exciting
time
and uh it's a very exciting
situation where the u.s was able to get
to
the metal round have the opportunity to
face the best team in the world
but frankly i was very fearful uh
of the fact that the soviets could blow
the u.s team out
and uh it could be four nothing or five
nothing
at the end of the first period and i
know when ken dryden and i walked
over to the arena our hotel was only
four or five blocks away
i think i said something along the lines
of if it's only 3-1 soviets midway
through the second period
that's not bad so
they scored first uh midway through the
first period
and i'm thinking oh man you know hold on
don't let it be two
three four nothing and then uh we get a
the tying goal and then they go ahead
again two to one
and then mark johnson scores that goal
with no time left at the end of the
first period
so we now have more than we asked for it
the amazing thing to me about
that game is it developed and it was so
interesting listening i haven't heard
jim
talk in those terms even you know 41
years later listening to how he
uh broke that game down in his mind
the most important thing in that game
was that jim never allowed it to be a
two-goal game
never it was one-nothing soviets it was
1-1
it was 2-1 soviets it was 2-2 it was 3-2
soviets and they dominated the second
period
outshot the u.s team something like 16-3
and jim made a number of saves you know
standing on his head
and that kept the us in the game and
enabled the tying goal to be scored
midway through the third and then of
course the original goal and then it
just got crazy i mean the last 10
minutes were insane the soviets are
skating
these crazy shifts on and off the ice
every 20 seconds the crowd is going
going wild and it was it was a one-off
and again you know you look at what jim
did in that game
how many times do you win a game when
the team is out shot 39-16
so that was that was nobody anticipated
what took place
how often do you watch it jim how often
do you actually sit there and watch it
back
you know i i think i've truly in 41
years now
watch the full game maybe once and
you know um the the point is you know
we all wanted to become in the national
hockey league american players had never
been
really accepted into the national hockey
league and so
you couldn't go in there and be proud of
what you had accomplished because to
them you had accomplished nothing
right and so you really could never ever
relax and feel good about what you
accomplished because you were
you always have another goal and so as
i've got older
you know i really said you know my son
is 32 years old i said
you know jd we should just sit and watch
this kid i should tell you about some of
these things and
you know it it's we're getting just to
that age rich where
we don't care you know what i mean it's
like
that was cool i could say this because
now
i'm like that i'm a grandpa you know i
can i can say those things nobody's
going to critique me for being happy and
but it was never like that so you know
you never watch that because you always
have a different goal in mind
now what about you you know
a story i have to tell you this is the
41st
anniversary is last year in a free
pandemic
it's the actual 40th anniversary
and the vegas golden knights invited the
whole team to come back
and be honored before the game at
t-mobile arena
in the proudest champion usa usa this is
40 years after the fact
that at least two-thirds of the people
in that building weren't even born
when this took place but they knew the
story they played a little video
beforehand and
to me one of the most astonishing things
after they announced
that the team one by one the guys came
out walking off the ice
you know to get back underneath the
stands
they had to pass by the the the golden
knights bench
and none of these guys were born at that
point and a lot of those guys
weren't even from the united states but
they were all like leaning over
the boards and hugging the american kids
it was like the american
team down in their 60s it's
almost as if everybody in the nhl
understood
what this meant to hockey in this
country
i've got jim craig and al michaels here
together on the 41st anniversary of the
miracle on ice
uh here on the rich eisen show jim what
what did her brook say to you
obviously we've seen the movie miracle
in that remarkable speech that kurt
russell uh playing herb
gave to the team about moments that's a
you know top-notch moment
in in sports movie history but what what
did herb say to you guys before
taking the ice um in the middle round
against
the russians you know it's really
interesting in
in in the work i do now which is
motivational speaking i always tell
people something i learned from her that
was really really important
and and that was time management right
and
you know everybody thinks priorities
everything else but the most important
thing in time management is knowing how
much time you have
because that drives all strategies right
you you can't
you don't know how to create a strategy
unless you know how much time you have
right and so her brooks trained us
and treated us the way he did because he
only had six months right
but when it came that night he was our
confidence
he absolutely believed in us he
absolutely loved us
each of us individually um
he knew how to take us to this different
level um he had recruited us
specifically
and you know i you know i wrote my book
we win one of the things in the studying
of herb that really became
so apparent to me was when he said
you're not looking for the best players
you're looking for the right players
what he meant is players that as a
leader you can coach
and players as leaders that you can get
them to go to some place
that they don't even know is possible
without your help
right and that's what great mentors do
so
what herb brooks was able to do was to
take each and every one of us and get us
to that spot
that we were prepared and he was proud
and he was our compliments so for me
it was different than it was for mark
johnson than it was for mark wells and
it was for jack o'callaghan
but it was the same because he had
brought us
to believe in a level like a lot of
people want to
tell a lot of leaders want to tell
people how to think
instead of making people think and
and herb brooks just had this ability
to reach into your soul and see
something that
you he was not going to let you get away
with not getting to
because and he he took on that
responsibility
and so to me the greatest thing about
herb was
that he he realized what our potential
was
and he treated us all differently to get
there
and then when we got there he became our
competence
and protector and uh
if you have want to have a real thing
watch the game against
check when mark johnson gets run by the
check and he tells me they'll take that
coho
and stuff it right down you know and i
can't even say the words right
but you know he he was just he was a
special man
a really special man now what are your
recollections of him i mean
what was he was he tough to deal with
from your perspective
or what was it from your
end with hurt brooks now i think it was
very tough for
the press but for me it was very simple
and for that i can thank ken dryden
because ken of course had won the
stanley cup
multiple times the best of the trophy in
montreal
and he had retired and of course ken is
unbelievably bright and
uh you know maybe the most book smart
athlete i've ever been
maybe the most book smart person i've
ever
encountered in my life and so herb
had this affinity you know with with ken
and he
wanted to pick ken's brain so as as a
consequence on every off night
brooks would come over to our hotel to
have a couple of beers
you know we'd have him for an hour so we
had
the access to brooks that nobody else
had
thanks to ken dryden but brooks was as
interested in what kenny had to say
as we were in trying to figure out you
know what we could glean
from what herb had to say he was
a fascinating man listening to you know
jim talking about him
i can see exactly what he did uh it all
worked out perfectly
and you know just another quick story in
in 2000 sports illustrated brought all
the great athletes
from the 20th century into madison
square garden for a
for a show on cbs and uh
they had the the top 10 greatest sports
moments of the 20th century
and this of course was number one and
they asked me to introduce it
and the team and herb comes out the team
gets 14 000 people in the garden that
night
place goes crazy so now we're walking
down a little staircase to go behind the
stage and i'm walking next to her
and herb says how could they vote that
number one
and i said herb won't you ever
understand
please enjoy what you enjoy what
happened it's the greatest
moment of the 20th century in sports
certainly in north america
so it was almost as if there was a part
of her
that just couldn't accept how fantastic
this was to everybody else
you know he was a coach look he could
have been the king of america
a week after the olympics what's he
doing he goes to switzerland
to coach a club team he was a hockey
coach
i love that stuff man i mean that's just
jim is there
is there a story that people don't know
about this because again it's 41 years
al's you know
mentioned again it was a the number one
sports moment of an entire sports
century um my kids are 12
10 and seven they know the story because
i made sure that at the very least they
saw the movie miracle and then of course
we start we went to youtube and
showed them moments of you know you and
you know your dad
obviously and we showed them these
moments and i get emotional just
thinking about
i get i i tear up i literally tear up
because of what it meant to me
in 1980 what it means to me now is there
a story
a story that that's never been told or
do we know everything about this
well you know when the kids look at the
movie and they see that they didn't take
the test
that you know disney asked me for some
political uh
license there okay what really happened
herb was so
bright that after my mother had passed
away
that he had me live with the team doctor
because i needed family
right what i didn't know is that he
checked in with a team doctor almost
every single night
and when we got that briggs meyer or
this type of assessment test
i you know i was always planning to take
that test but i did what i did every
night i called home and called my dad
and that particular night he was crying
he had just lost his job as a food
service director
to amara and he didn't really know what
to do
and so i had this aha moment that said
you know
how can i do my dreams with my
family is in a situation that they need
support
but my mother had made me make a promise
that i would never turn pro
uh if i had a chance to represent our
country see
the kids today don't understand it it
wasn't so much about being just an
olympian
it was about representing your country
right
and the olympian part was how you did it
but it was always about the flag and and
pride you know and that's
that was my dad's generation you know
that's what i grew up with that's what i
knew
right and so you know i i thought if i
didn't take this test that herb brooks
would send me home i wouldn't break my
mother's promise
and it would be really kind of an easy
thing to do i would go
because obviously we weren't going to
win and you know
this was just me being selfish what i
didn't know is her brooks knew all about
that
and the part that he loved best was
about my character that if i was
willing to give up being an olympian to
support my family
i was just the type of guy he wanted
right
and so here's what he said to me he goes
can you do your job i said yeah i can
he says okay i'm gonna help your dad and
he got a loan
from my my family nobody knows that and
what he did is he got me a comfort level
so that i could go out and do what i
wanted to do
if you look at her brooks and you think
of warren strelo one of the greatest
goalie coaches in the national
occupation
warren stralow would never have been
anything but a college goalie part-time
coach without her brooks what her brooks
did
is he saw a vision for warren in that
position
now everybody's got a goalie toast it
was nobody had a goalie coach then it
was even a position
it wasn't a full-time job right so
his her raising warren to a level that
warren couldn't get to
craig patrick becomes a general manager
because of her brooks the players become
these things because of her brooks right
and so
he was a very unselfish man
that was a teacher
and a motivator and if he didn't have
chaos he didn't know what to do
because he did he needed that that was
that was his
kryptonite or you know what whatever you
want to call that was
what it was that he wanted to do and and
he did it so well and when people said
he wouldn't be able to adjust
when he had the pros he adjusted and the
pros loved him you know what i mean
and so uh for me he's been an incredible
mentor
and so what he did that nobody knows
about is
he cared he really cared about people
and why this last is because
it was true and honest and not
fabricated
the flag going over my shoulders wasn't
some
agent telling me how to do it it was an
american
bringing it to the stadium they couldn't
buy them there
they jumped on the eyes that was touched
by a moment
right and and so what we did and what we
have
is what america is all about and that's
why it lasts
that's amazing jim you're amazing al you
too i guess
the last question i have here is clearly
you know this game was played at five in
the afternoon
um and uh america
is another part about it that's
unbelievable
uh that wouldn't really go down today is
that it was
held for america to see later on
tape delayed at what point jim did you
and the
team hear the phrase do you believe in
miracles when was the first time
is there a story behind that potentially
that you that actually came across you
that
that al's line that resonates still to
this day today is one of the greatest
lines in the history of sports
broadcasting when did when did that ever
reach you guys well i just remember it's
snowing in lake placid
jim lampley is taking my dad uh mike
ruizione
his dad we're walking down people are
surrounding us
and i think jim lampley said
you know l michael's cause of do you
believe in miracles and
you know it was it started there but you
know the greatest thing rich
is i'm now 60 almost four years old
every day i learned the importance
of what myself and my teammates were
able to accomplish
and how it affects people in such a
positive way
that that's the most refreshing thing so
people will ask me all the time
what's the greatest thing that ever
happened to you from the olympics
well when my mother died so did my dad
right but when those olympics
happened my dad was reborn you know he
was like the greatest gift there was
he was he was just a proud dad of a
having a son who was able to be part of
something that was bigger than ourselves
and so
the gift is it it's something that i
really feel that our team has taken as a
responsibility
to make sure that we are humble
respectful
and thankful for everybody who
paved the way for us and in our day it
was community
right it was your town it was your
people who never made you feel bad if
you didn't have any money
or you needed to borrow something it was
getting rides from neighbors it was
it was community right and and that's
what i truly think we represent and and
that's important to me
and i know it's important my teammates
and rich just the way
in i mean you know jim talks about what
it means 41 years later
to the people in this country and i've
said this a number of times but
it really resonates to me is that
you know when if you're of a certain age
you remember pearl harbor i mean you
have to be really old right now but
you remember pearl harbor a lot of us
remember obviously
when john kennedy was assassinated we
remember when bobby kennedy was
assassinated
we remember when the challenger blew up
we remember oklahoma city obviously we
remember we remember 911 and now we can
all remember
the insurrection of the capital think
about all of those events
all those events that people remember
every one of them is terrible
except lake classic that resonates in a
completely
different manner and it's beautiful and
you live to the moment al i mean and
you've done so many great things i told
you this
uh personally as well the fact that you
lived to the moment like that and
and and you found the economy of words
to nail it to
um it's quite something out 41 years
later
it was it's almost like they had the
script before it happened
yeah you you guys wrote the script what
i said came out of my heart
yeah but you know how the thing that's
so amazing is
ken dryden is so bright and a goalie
sees the play
going from and coming to so you have a
whole different perspective
and to listen to him talk
and see how excited he was and
a very unpartial unbiased
just such a professional person it it's
it's it's crazy how good it is
it's it's just too good you know what i
mean
it is and then the amazing thing too is
kenny had
never done this it was the first time
he'd gone into broadcasting he had just
retired
and i i met him in moscow he went over
to
scout a tournament in december of 79 i
was sitting there having dinner
and kenny is explaining to me in great
detail the difference between national
hockey league hockey
and international hockey and he says to
me at one point do you think this is the
type of thing
the american audience will be interested
in and i said kenny
yes but let me introduce you to the
world of broadcasting
can you get it down to eight seconds
yeah
and he did even the call like you know
the the us's are pending too much of jim
craig and they're raising
his scores i mean he was so i mean
everything he did
was the timing of a person who had been
there
you know what i mean it was just
fabulous fantastic
well yeah i could say the same thing
about this chat thank you so much guys
it means so much to so many people
and i'm so thrilled that my that you
allow me
through my show to bring this to um as
many people as possible on such a
special day al michaels thank you
and jim craig thank you yeah i'll always
love being
sharing some time to real professionals
in your industry
it's it's really fun to be able to share
a little bit of time and
you know it's just a happy moments it's
fun to remember thanks for sharing it
with me
and we'll we'll do we'll do 42 next year
i'm signing you up right now
okay buddy thank you look forward to it
that's uh
al michaels and jim craig here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here